[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing some of the
Wizarding world's most unpopular Harry
Potter opinions as with just about any
famous work of fiction the Harry Potter
series is the subject of many an opinion
since the first book the philosopher
stone came out in June of 199 7 fan
theories discussions and opinions have
run rampant after all the adventures of
Harry Potter take place within its own
Universe with an entire world of magical
law up for interpretation and while
there are many similar and therefore
popular opinions out there about the
Harry Potter books movies and characters
there are also quite a few unpopular
ones as well in today's video I'll be
taking you through some of these fan
opinions that lean more towards the UN
popular side of things starting off with
10 Harry should have learned more magic
faster considering that Harry found out
that he was a wizard and could do magic
at the same time that he discovered that
a Super Evil wizard had murdered his
family in an attempt to kill him it
seems a little odd that he doesn't put
more effort into his magical education
like immediately of course the majority
of the witing world believed Voldemort
to be dead and gone but if you heard
even the slightest whisper that the
person who'd once tried to assassinate
you and killed your parents might still
be around I imagine you'd get to work
figuring out how to defend yourself
wouldn't you and yet arry seems a lot
more preoccupied with his friendships
annual Mysteries around hog wo's castle
and the game of quiddit even when he
gets a bit older and the threat of
Voldemort's return becomes a lot more
likely and actually quite evident he
still doesn't seem to take his magical
education all that seriously sticking
with his trusty old expel armus and
being incredibly difficult with
Professor Snape as he attempts to teach
him emancy nine Hagrid is an overrated
character I don't agree with this one
but here it is rubies Hagrid The Lovable
half Giant and Hogwarts gamekeeper is
said by some fans to actually be one of
the most overrated characters in the
series why because although his love for
Harry was real and it seemed like he
genuinely cared for the people in his
life he really wasn't that great of a
person or role model to start with he
was quite prejudiced saying things to an
11-year-old Harry like there's not a
single witch or wizard who went bad who
wasn't in sutherin and never mess with
goblins Harry he also continually put
the students Harry included in danger
taking firste students out into the
Forbidden Forest at night and leaving
them alone to help him get his tasks
done faster finally when he was given
the care of magical creatur's teaching
position despite not having the proper
credentials he was quite negligent
bringing dangerous magical animals
around students without properly
educating the children on how to handle
them eight quiddit doesn't make any
sense there are fans out there who argue
that the Wizarding world's most famous
sporting event is in fact quite Bonkers
why is it played so high up in the air
why wouldn't there be standard
regulations on players broomsticks
especially in a school setting what's
the point of having dangerous balls
rocketing around to try and knock you
down and why on Earth would the majority
of any given Quidditch team Focus so
heavily on scoring measly 10-point goals
when catching the golden snitch and
earning 150 bonus points is clearly the
only thing that actually matters these
are great questions and to be honest I
don't disagree seven the movie
adaptation of Bellatrix was a disaster I
don't agree with this one either but let
me share the sentiment of others in the
novels Bellatrix of strange was clearly
a psychopath she was a devote deathy
who was willing to do dark and terrible
things in the name of serving Lord
Voldemort but she was also tactfully
manipulative incredibly smart and quite
put together in the movies however
Bellatrix the strange was a straightup
basket case who was more of a caricature
than a true adaptation of the much more
complex dark witch who graced the pages
of the books six Remis Lupin wasn't all
that likable as one of James Potter's
best friends and members of the
Marauders it's easy for fans to lump
rumis lopin in with some of the most
interesting and likable characters in
the entire series what's more he was
also a werewolf giving him an entirely
new and fascinating background that fans
had not learned about prior to his
character's introduction but if you
really look at the majority of his
interactions with Harry and the series
other characters he really wasn't all
that nice of a guy he helped his friends
bully sever Snape while he was a student
at Hogwarts despite knowing full well
what it was like to be different and and
unaccepted for who you are he also
didn't stand up for Sirus Black one of
his supposed best friends when he was
framed for the murder of his other
friends James and Lily in fact he
actually believed that Sirius was guilty
lastly he rebuked the affections of
nador Tonks rather unkindly on more than
one occasion despite also having
feelings for her five the teenage love
stories were unnecessary and weak now I
completely understand the need to
provide the young characters of Harry
Potter with some experience in the
dating world before ending up with their
forever person more on that in just a
moment but did there really need to be
so many flimsy teenage love stories
throughout the series I'm talking about
Harry and Cho Ron and lavender herion
and crumb and Jin and Dean in my opinion
and in some other fans as well these
courtships were mostly just distracting
from the larger narratives and more
interesting storylines four Dumbledore
was a terrible head Master Professor
Alber Dumbledore was many things famous
wizard magical mentor and lover of
sherbet lemons but spectacular
Headmaster not according to this fan
opinion to clarify many people have
talked about whether or not Dumbledore
was actually evil but not as many people
have openly said that he was just plain
terrible at his job this particular
opinion points out that he was rarely at
Hogwart school when he was needed like
when it turned out that Professor
Quirrell a professor who dumbledor had
hied actually had Voldemort on the back
of his head or basically whenever Harry
needed him he also constantly put the
student population in danger what with
the elaborate Maze of magical traps set
up inside the castle to protect the
philosopher stone allowing students to
stay at school when the Chamber of
Secrets reopened allowing students to
stay at school again when an escaped
convicted criminal was thought to be
targeting Harry at the school allowing
the incredibly dangerous Antiquated Tri
tournament to start up again shall I
continue better not or we'll run out of
time three creature was a better house
elf than Dobby like many fans I found
the death of the Beloved house elf Dobby
quite devastating he looked out for
Harry for years and we'd watched him
escape the Malfoy family and explore his
Newfound Freedom he was well intentioned
and selfless wasn't he well according to
some fans he was actually a lot more
annoying than anything else making
creature a lot more tolerable in their
minds the fact that creature and a
sympathetic storyline having helped
regular spack steal the Hulk rux only to
watch his master die during the effort
creature was loyal to the end although
it's hard to argue that Dobby wasn't
also so hard to say for me two the
ending was a little okay quite absurd if
you favor neat and tidy endings then you
likely loved the way that the Deathly
Hallows epilog chapter 19 years later
played out but for some fans this scene
was just too sickly sweet for their
taste the most common complaints revolve
around how perfectly the relationships
lined up with Harry and jinny ending up
together and Ron and herione also ending
up together and the names of their
children specifically Harry and jinny's
being almost as intolerable as their
relationships with each of the kids
being named after Dead characters in the
series from James Sirius Potter to Alba
SAS Potter and even Lily Luna Potter not
only are each of these names a little
morbid they're also just well really
cheesy one choosing Peter pettigru as a
Secret Keeper was a stupid Choice
throughout the series we come to learn
more and more about the death of Harry
Potter's parents James and Lily Potter
and how exactly they were killed not
only were they targeted and murdered by
one of the Wizarding world's darkest and
most evil wizards to ever live I'm of
course referring to Lord Voldemort they
were also betrayed by one of their
closest friends Peter petagrew or
wormtail as he was called by James and
their other friends friends wormtail's
betrayal came about not too long after
these friends had all graduated from
Hogwart School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry The Potters discovered that
Voldemort to believed their infant son
Harry would be his inevitable downfall
and therefore plan to kill him to
protect their baby and themselves they
magically concealed their whereabouts by
performing the fidelia charm and giving
their location to a Secret Keeper
instead of choosing James's best friend
Sirus Black or the only wizard Voldemort
has ever openly feared Alba Dumbledore
they opted for their other less talented
friend Peter because hey why would
Voldemort ever think to question that
guy but considering that at the time
there were known spies within their
Circle it really doesn't seem all that
wise for James and Lily to have chosen
to go with someone who they weren't 100%
confident in like James's best friend or
the all powerful Dumbledore or maybe
they were confident in Peter but that
still doesn't make it a smart choice now
does does it in fact the smartest Choice
may have been for them to be their own
secret Keepers and with that we've come
to the end of another video what did you
think what are your most unpopular Harry
Potter opinions please share your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel also be sure to check out the
content on Spotify as well as extra
content on my second Channel Harry
Potter Theory extra until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to
[Music]
live